eat up I see a few folks who are jumping
in now so as folks start to trickle in
we just wanted to get things started so
this is one of our first virtual meetups
for pi data Boston so fortunately as
much as we'd all love to kind of be with
been in person going having him lead us
through this we are doing this online so
definitely big shouts of ever be able to
do this and put this all together we
want to give a little bit more
information about pi data and so we're a
community in Boston that is supporting
the bigger PI data organization just
bringing people together to work on
different dated challenges as well as
being able to share best practices and
really share knowledge across all
different types of experience levels to
continue to really build a community
here in the Boston area around Python
other open-source tools I know we've had
a few folks who have jumped on and been
connected with us in person but as we
can see on the screen now definitely on
the meetup page make sure you're joining
follow us on hashtag on Twitter the PI
data site which has a lot of information
about all the other PI data chapters
across us definitely stay connected with
there and lastly we just want to touch
base on the code of conduct so I know a
lot of you folks who have been here in
person who have been able to come to our
events I realize that we're part of the
bigger PI data and um focus organization
we want to make sure that overall
everyone is respectful and really
supports each other within the community
and also understanding that again this
is an organization that we just want to
make sure that everyone feels welcome
and inclusive and so definitely trying
to be mindful of that one last thing we
want to jump on is that we're always
looking for folks to volunteer
definitely need people to put together
put together events here definitely
looking for speakers for the next couple
of virtual events right now we don't
have
venues or food or partnerships that we
look for at the movie but definitely
stay connected with us if you are
interested in any of those areas where
we're still active and trying to set
things up at some point when we all are
in person and able to meet up which is
definitely something we're looking
forward to and high data sight for the
PI data Boston community that'll
definitely be up with something that
we've been working on over the last
couple of months but definitely
definitely stay active in the slack
channel there's a lot going on there
within the boss type of data Boston
meetup as well as different or
organizers who are sharing information
there so if you're interested in
organizing and wanting to volunteer
definitely get on that slack channel in
addition to that where we're able to
also kind of collect different folks who
are interested in presenting as well so
definitely definitely get on that slack
channel and before I kick things off to
Ben do you want to give a shout out to
our next our next meetup which we're
gonna have in June it's already been
posted and shared out so definitely stay
connected take a look at that we have
causal modeling and machine learning by
Robert Ness and this is gonna be
happening next in June next month so be
on the lookout for that if you haven't
already joined stay tuned for a zoom
link coming but without further ado
we're all here for Ben be our ski who
was able to put together this awesome
workshop on NLP basics so I will not
keep anything for him at this point I'll
pass it over to him and let him give you
a brief introduction as well as take you
through the workshop awesome thanks fun
thanks so much Tyler yeah thanks for
taking us through that really excited to
be having this event really like to echo
what I was saying it would be great if
you know we could all be in person I'll
be sharing you know like stories and be
having a networking session here but I
mean it's great that people are
available and people can join us in this
time and yeah that we can continue to
build a cooking community as I was
saying so yeah we're recording now I
know there was a comment about that
previously so we can share that as well
all right
so I'm gonna start sharing my screen
let's see how this works all right so
can everyone
oops can everyone see this thumbs up
thumbs up great perfect fantastic so
here's the setup
I might yeah I'm gonna leave this on for
just a couple of minutes and you know
maybe people people don't mind the
sharing this in the chat as well this is
all the information you need to get
started I suggest that you use
collaboratory you'll probably need a
Google account to use it it'll have all
the packages and everything you don't
have to wrangle with docker but if you
really want to
there's the github as well you can feel
free to surround with that as well
notebook
specifically is the NLP workshop
notebook we'll be working from there and
the slides in PDF form should also be
there so just to give an overview what
we're gonna be talking about today is
we're basically going to be talking
about some kind of basic techniques in
natural language processing we're going
to be going from raw text informative
effectors and I'll talk a little bit
about more about what that means but my
goal here is to make this more workshop
II than it is like a lecture right and
so I have some exercises that we can
work on and try and do our best job to I
don't know if the breakout rooms are
gonna work I've tried that before and
sometimes but I want to make it a little
bit interactive so feel free to break in
if you have questions I'll take breaks
for doing the exercises and doing the
questions but you know they I imagine
you know we have this going until 9:00
but I imagine we'll probably wrap up and
you know probably about 8:30 or
something like that for additional
questions and things like that so
wherever we get to we get to in this
there's a lot of material and happy to
answer questions your you know after
that around 8:30 for for Q&A or
afterwards during the conversation the
slack or just again touch so just gonna
move on from here hopefully people have
this open a little bit about me so I'm
the Associate Director of data science
on the food supply chain analytics and
since a group at MIT Sloan my PhD is and
policy analysis that worked a lot in
natural language processing and you know
going from soup to nuts on a bunch of
different projects I have a website that
has a little bit my portfolio always
interested in making new contacts in new
projects and working with people so feel
free to get in touch you know on my
website on github Twitter all those
things so feel free to reach out so
let's get started about what is the
motivating reason for like why we should
care about natural language processing
and I'd say the main thing is that
there's been a lot of data growth and
that's like what's given a lot of the
major innovations that you see in
machine learning that there's just a lot
more a lot more information out there
and I love this graphic on the left cuz
it's just like and this is in 2017 right
this is already out of date it's
probably a lot more than that but it's
like every minute of every day YouTube
you know they're watching 4 million
videos are being watched at one time
spam email sent Google has for them four
million searches being conducted every
minute this is a lot of information and
a lot of that information is not like
just signal right like it's not just
information that we can take you plug
into a machine learning algorithm or
like information that tells us something
like intrinsically about a user or about
anything a lot of this is unstructured
data a lot of it is you know images its
videos and it's text like in my
experience text is the the major data
source that a lot of companies are
dealing with and they don't necessarily
know how to deal with this and so the
idea is you want to be able to you know
get get your hands dirty with text data
pretty quickly and you can like for with
very basic so the basics that we're
gonna go over here you can uncover a lot
and we'll go over that so what is
natural language basically the
definition of natural language is a
language that has developed naturally
right that's kind of basic but you know
that's in contrast to something like
artificial language or computer code I
like just putting these two things side
by side like look at what natural
language looks like and look what a
computer code this is just a Python for
looks like Python for loop is very basic
right word basic very like linear right
it's very if yes then do this if no then
do this and you know there's
abstractions of course on top of that
but it is you know you can visualize it
as a graph the same as you can visualize
natural language the natural language is
a little bit more complex right we have
this very simple dependency grammar
graph which you know has some
information in it but definitely not all
of the information that's contained
within language but you can see that
it's a lot more kind of nuance there's a
lot of additional like you know like
these parts of speech are just sort of
abstractions on top of it so the point
of putting these things side-by-side is
that natural languages is very complex
as is computer language but it's usually
a little bit harder to say what is the
you know if this word appears does this
mean does it mean it's positive if this
word appears doesn't mean negative
things like that doesn't work as well in
natural language as it does in computer
language so on that point the early
forms of processing natural language
were basically turning them into
computer language right this is from the
1950s a lot of the problems were this is
for machine translation and it's kind of
hard to read here I guess but the idea
is a bunch of rules so if you see a
certain word followed by another word in
within a certain amount of space below
blah blah you build this entire
essentially rules engine to do
translation right you can say like okay
now this word means this this is the
subject this is the object stuff like
that and it doesn't work particularly
well because it's hard to take that very
complex and natural language and then
put it into kind of a rules engine so
you know jump ahead to more modern
techniques and these are like deep
learning models where basically it takes
the information it condenses it down
into informative representation that has
a lot of context as a lot of nuance to
it and then output something so this is
also a machine translation model but
this is a more modern machine
translation sequence the sequence
encoder decoder model and you can see
that it's you know I'm mixed
extracting around away all of the
complexity here but it's it's different
from you know things have changed a lot
in even the past few years and
definitely in the early days of natural
language processing when it was sort of
indistinguishable from just kind of
rules engines and heuristics and things
like that so now that we had this cool
technology that you know has these
informative representations and can do
all these fancy things we can do cool
things like writing right with
transformer and I if you haven't heard
of this please mess around it's so much
fun like I put in if you put in the seed
basically the model can complete the
sentence or just continue writing just
based on the information you've given it
just on what words are likely to come
based on the context and so I just the
only thing I wrote here is I'm attending
a PI data Meetup and the rest was
written by the model right and it's
sensible right like you know we do know
operate specific time and you know it's
kind of what is a Python application but
like it's it's you can it's coherent
right it's actually a sentence a
complete sentence we can also do cool
things like this which I actually might
play I think this is only a couple
minutes but it's a Google assistant
making a reservation can people hear
this if I play this this is curable no
no okay well all right so the this I
definitely recommend looking at this but
basically it's a machine that is making
a reservation and if I can just so the
person on the the person that they call
is an actual person who is responding
like how many people are you I was
making this reservation for and it even
like the person on the other end of the
phone doesn't understand what they're
saying there's like four how many people
and the assistant even processes that
and is able to understand like oh you're
asking me again for this piece of
information I gave you so it just it
just sounds very natural and it's all
you know the fancy techniques that exist
in this area as of the past
of years and always worth discussing as
part of this like even though these
things all seem miraculous and magical
they are subject to the datasets they
give them so if you give them a data set
that has bias into it it will learn that
bias and this is an example of the
association between the pronouns he and
she and particular other words that are
professional words and you can see that
captain is much stronger associated with
heat than it is with she nurses much
stronger associated with she than is
this is just one kind of illustration of
some of the issues that exist in baked
into you know though if it's part of the
data that you're giving to your model
it's part of what the model similar so
are there any thoughts or questions up
to that point that sort of like a little
bit of background like where we're at
okay so I'll just go forward them so I
just have a list of a couple of LP
libraries here you know not included are
some of the deep learning libraries you
know I torches is pretty powerful in
this in this area but we'll be focusing
on Spacey and so I could learn are the
two tools that were mainly going to be
using ltk is something you'll see in a
lot of tutorials I think it's super
powerful and it's really good for people
who are doing like research that's like
a lot more mmm say like linguistics
focused a lot more like the choices some
of the design choices that we'll talk
about in this in the course of this
workshop are have a lot more
functionality in ltk but spacings I
could learn a little bit more performant
and if you want to get you know do some
exploratory data analysis pretty quickly
I find spacing and so I could learn more
useful then again I've also coded a lot
more in spacing so I can learn so maybe
if I had work experience but then I'll
gkf these are just some of the libraries
that are out there so let's we're gonna
about to jump into the code
I think it probably makes sense to talk
about tokenization first this is the
first step right so we have you know I
don't I don't have it like an example
right here but we have a text right we
have any you know document any sentence
anything the first step is to take that
you know string and break it into
smaller strings break it into useful
units and so a token can be defined as
basically a useful semantic unit a lot
of times word and token are used
interchangeably they are different
things and even sometimes tokens are our
punctuation sometimes tokens are parts
of words sometimes tokens are like
special they're not even words they just
are indicators of things and we'll see
some examples of that
so Spacey is the one that we're mainly
going to be using and Spacey its
structure is basically it's organized
around languages language modules and so
in a particular language like English
has a language specific pipeline and in
the base form it just contains a
tokenizer it makes a bunch of design
decisions around tokenization that are
abstracted away from you so you don't
have to really deal with that more
complex models more models the other
models might actually have a pipeline
components things like entity
recognition dependency parsers things
like that and we'll show some an example
of a more complex piece like that but
and the base form text will run through
this tokenizer and the output is a
docking bay sees version of the document
documents are composed by spans which
are sets of tokens and then the
individual tokens have attributes like
are they an entity are they alphanumeric
all they're all they all these other
things will mess around with that and so
I just have this question at the end you
might you know Spacey does a lot of
magic and it does it very performant but
Spacey makes decisions around
tokenization that you might want to
understand and we'll see some examples
why that understanding and design
decisions around that will sort of
change things so we'll jump into the
code unless there are any questions
right now in here
hearing that I'm gonna move on let's see
if I can actually see my screen here all
right okay so check in real quick is Co
laboratory or the code sort of working
with people I know it looks like the
chat is kind of going going mad here
okay but for the most part unless I hear
differently I'm gonna assume that people
are at least seeing this or able to
follow along in some way okay thumbs up
thumbs up fantastic all right so this is
just to ensure that the environment the
kernel has all the libraries that will
be using Spacey scikit-learn and pandas
so here's what I mean by the Spacey
languages so Spacey has a language
module and in that language module are a
set of base languages we're using the
English one mainly I want to just show
an example with with Chinese actually
you don't end up needing to download
this which is interesting apparently
colab already has this which is weird
but so I just want to show an example of
tokenization and how tokenizer differs
for different languages and I think
Chinese is an interesting one because if
you run this you'll see that the English
tokenization of a Chinese string is just
to complete this as like one unique
tokens like okay I don't know what this
is it's just one token right and then
you know the punctuation meanwhile if
you use the proper Chinese tokenizer it
sees that these are different words and
I don't shine these speakers so I don't
know if this is particularly the right
tokenization to be using but you can see
that the it behaves a little differently
so now we're just going to talk about
how you can basically make these tokens
right the whole point here is to take a
string like this Chinese string or let's
let's go with an English string right
like this English string and
into a set of informative semantic units
or a turn into tokens and you know what
are those informative semantic units are
a whole a matter of design choices and
so now we're going to talk about some of
those design choices so one of the
things that sort of comes up in every
tutorial is about lowercase right and
bass Python you can just take a string
and turn it into its lower case form
spite Spacey has a similar pretty simple
way of doing this and they do similar
things you know obviously this is
breaking it into individual tokens based
on the model and so that's just you know
thinking about lower casings kind of you
might not just want to out of the box do
lower case lower casing because for
example you can see that now NLP is
lower case lower case NLP may have no
meaning to some models so we'll talk
about entity recognition a little bit
later but it's a lot easier for a model
to recognize an entity if the
capitalization is intact but you also
don't want to have things like the the
we hear that the capital W we hear to be
treated differently from something like
and we enjoy if if you if you lowercase
everything the two wheels are going to
treat the same if you don't lower case
everything then the this week and this
we are going to basically be different
units so just just want to point that
out and that's going to be true
throughout right like thinking about
what is it useful syntactic unit is
useful handling non alphanumeric text so
in bass Python you might this is one way
to do it you can just take out anything
that's not white space or an uppercase
or lowercase or a number Spacey has a
way of just removing if it's
alphanumeric but something worth noting
and I have that in the next cell is
thinking about contractions so when you
try to remove non-alphanumeric care
actors from contractions you get with
bass Python you get we we are turned
into war and with Spacey it actually
just drops the apostrophe re entirely
because that's not health in the
American right that's a as a punctuation
market so these are just points to show
that thinking about how the how these
things operate out of a box is important
and will change your result you might
want to treat contraction somewhat
differently might want to expand it
there's a bunch of different strategies
around that so how does that how does
that sound
are there thoughts or questions on that
cool so I have an exercise here we're
gonna see how this works right maybe we
take a couple of minutes I take a drink
of water and people try and create a
tokenizer just based on what I have
right you can just essentially if you
really want to just take copy of the
code that I have here and make a
tokenization strategy here I have an X
in the notebook already is my
implementation but try and make your own
implementation and feel free to share
questions in the chat or just speak up
with a question will do just maybe like
a few minutes to try this out just make
a little bit more interactive so let's
let's try that now all right thanks for
the insight my name is Coco so regarding
the punctuation where the meaning of the
word can get changed if you were to
remove these punctuation what is what
are the strategies how do you deal with
that with a word meaning other than
change are you saying how you deal with
contractions yeah yeah so there's a
couple of different ways of doing that
there's packages that automatically
based on a heuristic sort of do this
expansion if you don't if you don't hear
spacey will tokenize it in a fairly nice
way and essentially you end up with this
token which is apostrophe re which is
which is fine unless you want to do an
expansion then you might have to explore
something like a contraction expansion
bring any other questions or thoughts or
ideas I mean I don't know that somebody
has a way of dealing with the
contractions that's within space yet and
really messing around with the torch
yeah but anyway alright so we'll take a
couple minutes feel free to try and make
your own tokenizer and yeah then we'll
jump back into it
you
all right so let's jump back into it um
here we go
okay so yeah I'll just go through so I
mean I guess maybe does anybody have any
really want to share their their
technique for creating a tokenizer or
any or their thoughts on doing this
exercise because if there was anything
that came up
you
you
did this sort of work as an exercise I
have a couple exercises throughout and I
just want to make sure I give people
time to complete them it's a little bit
easier for in person then we can like
chat about a foot
all right so let's just we'll just move
along and feel free to break in if you
have questions about this I have three
different tokenization strategies here
just to show off a little bit of the
different capabilities of Spacey you
know we've seen the lower attribute from
the different tokens we've seen is alpha
another neat piece that comes from the
base model is it like a URL that's just
based on set of regular expressions and
I find it pretty cool too right now I'm
gonna use a URL and so if we take this
tokenize lower alpha URL and we take
what's it called text data when we run
it we get our sets of tokens for each of
the different sentences and in this case
the token eyes that removes any URLs
you'll see that it'll take out that URL
entirely right it doesn't remove
punctuation from it it actually takes
out the URL so maybe you want to change
it so it's includes URLs and doesn't
doesn't treat them as individual words
or anything like that you might want to
do that so that's just one technique
tons of techniques but again this is
assigned decisions and they sort of they
will definitely affect your results
we'll see more examples of that as we as
we go forward so I'm gonna jump back
into the slides real quick and to talk
about stemming versus lemons a stone so
has anyone heard of either of these
techniques before stemming over
somatization I can't really see
everybody here but okay well so it's
something that you always sort of see in
these tutorials NL CK has a ton of an
entire like stemming sort of area where
they can do any kind of different
stemming and and also has the capacity
to do limit ization
basically you know the idea is where
in this free text and we want to distill
it into the useful semantic units and
the idea is to get information that is
useful out of these units right so it
might not be useful to have a bunch of
different forms the word process or or B
we're doing or stuff or something like
that you might want to treat them all
the same and so one approach just sort
of reducing them to a common form is
stemming another is lemon ization so
stemming basically is just a set of
heuristics the idea is that it
transforms words usually the suffixes
into a more common form and you can see
the output of pi stemmer here where it
says he does natural language processing
gets reduced to he you know does what
the s removed natural language and
processing with the ing so you can see
that that's a little bit that reduces
any instance of does into it's sort of
common form there's other versions of
this that I've seen I think a good
example is taking something like Pony
vs. ponies and a lot of these heuristics
approaches will turn ponies into Pony
right it'll take that plural form into
into that form but you know it's not
really the same as as Pony right like
those are those are they're going to be
treated as two different tokens so
something that might be useful in that
case is lemon ization lemon ization is
basically reducing a word into its
dictionary form into its like base form
dilemma and that the the result of that
process you can see here where he is
doing natural language processing
becomes he be do natural language
process right and so you can see that it
transforms the word entirely right so is
becomes be becomes into this lemma form
where a stemming leaves intact most of
the word the most part so it's you know
it's a matter of Dastak you know you
make the decision whether you want to do
stemming bristle organization
so I tend to prefer to do do limit
ization just because of examples like
that where if the point is to reduce it
to its common form I prefer to not have
these kind of strange tokens like Pony
with uh I included in there
so I tend to use lemon sensation and
Spacey has a nice implementation of
elimination which I will show here so
remember I said that Spacey has
different kinds of pipelines some that
are very base and just have a base set
of functionality some that are a little
bit more complex and build other things
into the pipeline beyond just
organization this is a you know step up
more complexity of English models and
you need that to able to enable you to
do lemma because you actually need the
dictionary form of these different words
and that's not in the base English model
so I don't know if this will work right
out of the box sometimes it does with Co
laboratories kind of sometimes magic
sometimes confusing but so once you load
this in and you use that model to run
the text through you can see what comes
out of it and here it takes the pronouns
and turns it into the special pronoun
token I'm not a huge fan of that but
it's it's something that is uniformed
behavior and so you can guarantee that
things like anything that's a pronoun is
going to be turned into something like
that right so yeah so that's living
limit ization and stemming and we're
just alumina zation with this Spacey
basically doesn't have stemming that I
know of but I guess and that's another
reason why I use limitation a lot more
any thoughts on that I know there's it's
a wild debate about was better stemming
versus limit ization I don't you know
there'll be a fun debate to have at some
point probably not here I had a quick
question from if the text you're looking
at contains slang and there's
information that you want to capture in
that slang maybe to do you know kind of
group people who
you have a similar vernacular do you
have a are there pros and cons of
stemming versus limit ization and if so
what what would be each yeah that's it
that's a really good point yeah so I
mean I don't know just people have a
formula answer to that or people have
experience with that that they want to
bring up
so in my experience it's it is hard to
you know I one of the examples I've
worked with is like text messages and
text messages are a lot of shorthand and
things like that
and there's a lot of heuristics with
involved in both methods and so you
might have it changing a token that it
shouldn't be into a base form I'm trying
to think of an example to talk to my
head but yeah so lemma it's going to try
and like take anything that it senses is
not in its base dictionary for my turn
it to its dictionary form and if that's
like a slang that doesn't mean the
dictionary form that it's being
translated to you'll lose that piece of
information
I see somebody has a question here
tokenization keeps making nested lists
so oh yeah
so right yeah we'll talk about that
we'll talk about actually creating a
vocabulary and a little bit cool any
other comments thoughts
sorry justjust mm-hmm used to follow up
so it sounds like if if you are
interested in pulling information out of
slang mate - be very careful when you're
using you the limit ization or or
stemming yeah yeah and we'll talk a
little bit about so this is breaking it
down to very very my new control over
the individual tokens we're gonna
abstract some of this away and create
vocabularies and you can do it a little
bit more cleanly by examining your
vocabulary or curate and your vocabulary
right because your vocabulary should be
the informative the information that
you're extracting from the raw text or
the first level of information that
you're extracting from raw text and this
is this is all just decisions you might
make in designing your your vocabulary
cool alright so we'll move right along
alright so stop words so let's talk
about stop words so stop words are in a
extremely common words that have little
information so again we're going back to
this example this this motivating idea
where we want to have our the
information distilled from text to be as
informative as possible we want these
tokens to be as informed as possible and
so extremely common words have not a lot
of information in them and so you can
think of common words like the and from
and - and there's not a canonical list
of these stop words right
so there's consequences to being too
strict about them and there's
consequences to being too broad about
them so in looking at this example here
that in May 2020 I went to a pi day to
meet up in Cambridge can somebody tell
me what they think some of the stop
words just based on the definition are
[Music]
yep yep I yeah I is a good one right so
that one I wouldn't think of off the top
of my head but actually if you run it
through Spacey's set of soft words I
gets removed and I would actually say
that I is pretty informative right so
it's not I you know depending on how you
define stop words is sort of a question
but I actually does get removed in these
stock words so we're gonna just go and
just show essentially how the faci deals
with stop words and you can actually
just do this with the base English model
and again it's just a tribute of
particular token where you just say if
it's not a stock word or if it is a stop
word remove it right and so what's
interesting about this too and a and I
or moved in is removed as we've sort of
talked about may gets removed does
anybody want to guess why may gets
removed
maybe the process doesn't see it as a
month but you know is it I may be able
to do something right exactly exactly
that so it is case insensitive in what
it's doing right so it looks up may sees
it in stopped word dictionary and
removes it or marks it as the attribute
is stopped it's gonna be true so again
these are all just like gotchas a little
bit but they are design decisions and
they will affect the outcome of what
you're what you're working so
non-standard tokens is my word for all
of the things that kind of don't fall
into you know stock words or the other
the pieces that I've already sort of
talked about so I'm gonna talk a little
bit about named entities so the two
things that I'm gonna show examples of
are Tourelles and named entities I treat
them a little bit differently since URLs
are they don't really fall in the
definition in my opinion of named
entities but they are sort of the
special tokens into themselves right
they they aren't just a components of
slashes and periods and things like that
right they are something different and
should be treated you know you don't
want to just I mean you can just remove
all the punctuation and then just treat
them as a big block of characters which
is fine but then you get into issues
like does it have HTTP it doesn't have a
GPS and things like that so with named
entities a named entity is basically a
real world named object like a person
place or organization and the motivating
thing here is that New York City is not
just the tokens New York and City right
the token new means something in New
York City means something particular
that is different from the word new as a
new car a new new class or something
like that right so you want to be able
to treat them as sort of semantic units
themselves right they're in they have
information just all together in context
right and so there's a couple of
different approaches to identify these
you might use just an inventory you
might use pattern matching like you know
if it's a first name last name
sort of thing or you might use like an
actual model that is trained to identify
these things so based on the definition
that I've given right here can somebody
just call out some of the named entities
in this statement today the Cambridge
anything else Meetup
maybe yeah I mean I would say meetup as
well but interestingly it won't appear
unless it's like capitalized which is
getting back to that point before it'll
just be treated as whatever its own
thing so what about May 2020
- Leigh you know I know the answers to
the question that I'm asking so it's but
May 20 2010 today in itself right the we
actually just saw an example where May
was removed right because it was just
sort of treated as May as I may do
something but May 20 2009 the context
with May capitalized means something on
its own right it's a particular date so
so those that sort of outlines whether a
named entity is so I'm going to show
some code doesn't people have questions
on like just a conceptual review of it
so does somebody have a question good
okay perfect so this is just an example
of a couple ways that you can deal with
URLs we looked at like URL before but
here is a reg X approach to it this is
not particularly robust so I don't
recommend using it if you're already
using Spacey why not use Spacey's
built-in way but just to show that you
can sort of do this in a red X based way
just remove the punctuation if it
matches a certain pattern
and here I actually replaced it with
replace the URL with like a special
token which is a consideration you might
do right you might not want to just
remove the URL but replace it with some
kind of token that's gonna be maintained
so with named entities again we're gonna
load this a small model and we're gonna
run it through the model and we're gonna
get all the tokens out and each
individual token or the document itself
has an attribute that's called X and
it's basically a list of these different
entities that have their own set of
information to attach them so when you
run it through you can see it goes I am
attending a meet-up on Zoom May 27th
2020 sumit identifies as a person for
some reason I guess zoom was people and
it identifies this full May 27 28 and
that's and like that entire thing is a
named entity and these this space
explain is really useful it gives you an
explanation of the labels and you can
use this for part of speech things as
well but in this case just explaining
what it means by a person or a date any
thoughts questions on that
cool so let's do another exercise
because they're fun so we're gonna take
this text data again and we're gonna
build a comprehensive tokenization
pipeline so you're tokenization strategy
that you already made in the exercise
before you can probably just adapt it
now to maybe do a little bit more
complexity right like no big deal with
stop maybe just remove stop words remove
URLs identify named entities or
something like that right you can do a
number of different things I just
encourage you to try it out mess around
with it you can feel free to take the
example that I wrote about as well and
expand it so we'll just take say three
three or four minutes on that and then
we'll just jump back feel free to ask
questions in the chat or verbal
all right
okay so we'll jump back into it any
questions that came up where people want
to share their discoveries or their
their solutions
okay so I'll just just share mine so
this is a little bit elaborate you know
I had small ambitions when I first tried
to write this and ended up being a
little bit more complex and I kind of
wanted it to be but the idea is it gives
control over you know what you want to
do with any of these what you want to
stop words it includes all these things
about lowercase alpha alpha American and
romanization it's a little bit hard to
deal with the entities because I didn't
find an easy way and what I wanted to do
is to be able to replace the entities
with the type Vantage type and so that
required me looking at all of the
entities that were all the tokens that
were in a particular span labeled as an
entity and replacing all of those within
the tokenization the tokenized list so
that was maybe not the best approach but
it's added a little bit of complexity
into my tokenization pipeline but
basically for each of the tokens for
each of the documents for each of the
tokens it'll go through it'll you know
it can replace the URLs with the URL
token it'll basically collect entity
information and then once it gets to
outside of that entity replace the where
the entity was with the entity type and
do all the stop words and alphanumeric
magic there so if we run this on all the
text with all of these parameters we get
these lists of tokens for entities as
false we want to replace all the
entities and that works like this so
we're limit isn't limit izing everything
pronouns become that special token
entities become their own sort of
special token any thoughts on that I
mean also you know the people came up
with neat ideas for replacing entities
that's actually I'd be interested to
know actually
please into the obstruction built-in
here so I say yeah it's entity
extraction yeah yeah well so we're I'm
using Spacey's model space he already
has an entity recognition model baked
into this this model this English model
and they have other languages as well
but I'm just using that and I won't go
into the real details here but
individual tokens will have a tag for
whether they are the start of the token
sort of an entity inside of an entity or
they're outside of identity and
basically you can use that functionality
okay so the entity type like whether
it's a location or a person or oh and if
you were to combine stemming and lemma
is that a good practice and if you like
if you were to do it in which order
would you do it for stepping first lemma
second I would not do them together I
can't see a reason why that would I
don't think that would work as as either
method is intended to work it's not a
good idea to mix the two I don't think
so I think they're both trying to get it
the same thing and I think that standing
changes the words intrinsically and
limit evasion changes words in terms of
clean so you get a little bit different
things I don't know if people have
thoughts on that if the NDA example
where they do the pca component analysis
in the past which had both stepping in
my mind I was wondering there was a bad
practice there are maybe I was reading
it
no there's no I wouldn't say bad or good
practice I wouldn't do it it seems like
overkill were not overcome and this
seems like yeah it doesn't seem like a
reason to it to do it but maybe for a
particularly use case that's appropriate
one last question do you know how many
entity types are there in this library
like if they're like a pigsty you are
quite beyond it like a little further
make it intense it's in the tents it's
not even in the tens I think it's even I
think it's less than that no I think
there might be six does anybody know so
I know there's like there's a Geo
there's like for the country is with
people this dates is yeah this geo like
yeah I think there's only like five or
six I don't know if people have know off
the top of their head but it's somewhere
right so looking at the chat right there
Stanford yeah this is one model right
this Spacey space Webb trained on Webb I
forgot exactly I think it's on Wikipedia
explore them especially if you're doing
something scientific there's something
called size Spacey and there's a bunch
of model a bunch of language models that
are trained them that have specific
entities for science so like you know
chemical and animal and things like that
right this is a more you know all
purposes model but there's a ton out
there
cool so this was sort of a question
before like alright so we're you know
really digging into this like creating
of these tokens and essentially it's all
a matter of designing essentially a
vocabulary that you're going to use to
represent your documents in some
informative way and so one of the
informative ways that you can represent
your documents is five word counts word
count over your vocabulary and so I'm
just gonna show a method to do that with
sorry I'm just going to jump real quick
I want to make sure that I'm not
skipping over anything yeah I am
skipping over everything okay perfect
so so what I was saying the the
representation of documents across your
vocabulary is something that you could
that is usually referred to as a
document term matrix so this comes from
another field that's called information
retrieval basically there are a whole
whole thing is to extract signal from
noise and it's they have a whole suite
of techniques that are very useful in
NLP and basically just representing
these different documents in some
informative way and so as I was saying a
document term matrix is your documents
split across for your terms so you can
see this illustration is who I do not
have this credit I'm sorry this is from
a stand for this is from
here apologies for that but also
incurred thus textbooks that is
fantastic and is all for you anyway so
this is actually like they have a good
illustration but it's actually a term
document matrix but you know you can
just slip it and thence the document
just by looking at this you can get some
like useful information there right
julius caesar and henry v are you know
focused on a lot of battles and war and
stuff like that and so the word battle
appears a lot more frequently so just
looking at this very simple
representation you get something useful
out of it you can also do cool things
like term term matrix that's
particularly useful in word vectors
which we are not going to talk about but
it's essentially how often a particular
word appears in another words context in
other words document and that's cool
because you can see like very clear
things like this again this this text
book is fantastic because you can this
is a really good example of digital and
computer appear a lot together but
digital and pi don't appear maybe if it
was raspberry pi it would appear but it
doesn't appear here but it so let's go
back and jump right back to looking at
word counts unless there were questions
there a compose with a question
the term term matrices sure and maybe I
missed something but I think he's like
like co-occurrence two words occur
together in the same document yeah this
one particularly is two words appear in
the same document oh okay right yeah
okay but yeah and word vectors in glove
vectors it's this or all with what word
vectorization you might have a window
right like word two words appear within
three words of each other and I'm
different I measure but this is just
this one particularly it's just docking
time okay thanks cool so so this is
we're just gonna initialize this
distance by simple tokenizer we're using
it just because it's simple and so we
can do some tokenization here and so
just to clarify what it looks like now
all of that work that we've done so far
gets us to a nice pretty list of tokens
how nice is that and so you can use base
Python to just get word counts out of it
what is cool about these counter objects
is that you can add them together and
get a combined count so it's super fast
and doesn't require you to pull in any
psych it learns or Spacey or anything
like that and you can already get just a
count by these different documents of
the different words but I mean in most
use cases you're probably gonna want to
pull in something that just does this
without you messing around with
particular counter objects and so I
could learn count vectorizer
rather is super powerful super optimized
and very very good for this purpose and
you can get exactly the same thing that
we got above just by running this code
using plugging your own custom tokenizer
scikit-learn has its own tokenizer if
you don't specify a default tokenizer
and that's I believe just based on the
word boundaries like just white space
between between words and it does a
bunch of other it has a bunch of other
defaults you can see them all here and
again so these are design decisions that
you might want to look into if you want
to just use I can learn and not try to
build your own tokenizer
but this is another way to get to your
word counts what is cool here is so I
could learn by default using its compact
Dreiser outputs a sparse array which is
a particular data type and it's useful
because in most cases your vocabulary is
going to be a lot a lot larger than your
your document list and particular
documents may not have any instances of
particular items in your in your
vocabulary so it makes sense the
represented in a more compressed format
where it's just like most of the entries
are going to be 0 anyway
but this transformation gets you back to
essentially the same combine count that
we had before or in that we have up here
and he talks with questions on that
alright so I'm gonna move the head
unless people yeah I don't I kinda wanna
like maybe cut this to move to QA around
8:30 ish so I might just move forward
unless people feel differently about
that
okay well so this exercise is just you
can do sentiment analysis with what you
have right now where you don't need a
fancy fancy machine learning model to
get some interesting things out of the
cam vectorizer and you have them right
you can just say how many times does the
word good appear in these reviews how
many times the word bad experience right
the point of if you are not lower
chasing them which happens by default
and the count vectorizer you get a
different count and so your results
already look different just based on
those design decisions it's okay so
we're gonna try this on a real data set
because we're playing around with these
little data sets a little bit too much I
have a subset of the IMDB a data set for
reminding D being that has sentiment
positive and negative reviews it is in
the repo you'll have to in your collab
instance upload it and then you know
directed to that data location or if
you're running it at home we're gonna
have to change the data location that
working pairs anybody having trouble
with that I just saw a little pop up in
the chat it seems like yes
ooh cold cursing okay
sorry there was an interesting in common
but I'll get back to it okay so let's
let's just load that in so we have about
1200 negative and positive reviews we're
gonna run it through our count
vectorizer and when we get the top 10
words and how useful is that right what
are all those words does anybody
remember what what those words are
called
they're stop words right oh yeah
exactly so then like so we're running
right now the negative reviews right and
the idea was we wanted to look the top
ten words that are in negative reviews
and then compare it to the positive
reviews right and so what are we going
to see in a say the same thing right
it's basically filled with there's too
much noise in this signal right if
there's there's a bunch of stop words
and that's why we've made all the
decisions and done all the work before
because we want to try and distill it
down to something a little bit more
informal so they're not informative
about the content so we're gonna do some
things that make it a little bit more
informative we're going to use like it
learns own the convict eyes are English
stock words we're going to use our same
tokenizer we're also going to use these
additional parameters that govern how
weather words infrequent words are being
included in the vocabulary or overly
frequent words are being included in the
vocabulary so that's min document
frequency max document frequency so past
appear and at least one percent of the
corpus and no more than ninety percent
those pieces make sense people stop you
can commute bus and you know or even
better can you pass the space we have a
zone yes I don't know exactly where that
lives but yes you can pass a sea stop
words or right you can just build that
into your tokenizer to remove those this
is just you know so I could learn has a
way of doing it as well and they have
their there they're not the same right
Spacey stop words and psychic - what's
up words are not the same so that's
something worth considering so when we
run this do we get something informative
out of it yeah sorry about that error so
I would say that this is informative
right because sorry this is not labeled
but it runs negative first and then
positive and the negative corpus we see
bad
in one of the top ten words right in the
positive purpose we see great appearing
in the top 10 words we also see good
appearing in both of them but it's more
frequent in in the positive reviews so
look at that we just did sentiment
analysis without any machine learning so
that's that's kind of cool just to show
that you can do exploratory data
analysis really cheaply really quick so
any questions on that or comments on
that is machine learning though yeah
none of it comes from yeah machine
learning is like a set of heuristics
that you've sort of tuned and tweaked
yes
that's the spirit oh hi programming type
of parameters to the machine transform
function you learn it right I guess yeah
you're not yeah you're not like fitting
a classifier to it right like you're
just you're your design decisions have
gotten you to something informative
right without having to and this is
something you gonna have to do anyway
right even if you're gonna pass this
then into a classification model you're
gonna have to have a vocabulary so you
know this is not going to take the place
of your classifier but at least you've
done already so much glory analysis that
gives you some idea if there's some
signal that you can then probably build
a classifier so stop words Oh everybody
said stop words okay cool you think it's
a good idea to use max features yeah you
know good bad ideas I'm not gonna say
anything is a bad idea because then I'm
gonna get in trouble but I I think I
like this min document frequency max
document frequency because it logically
what you're trying to do is I don't want
super rare words and noise up my data
and I don't want super common words to
noise up my data
yeah if anybody's having trouble
actually loading the data set just make
sure that you are going to so if you're
at this screen right you go to this
little file manager and then you want to
upload that pickle file so that
shouldn't it's yeah it's you'd have to
upload the end if you let it sit for a
while it's gonna disappear anyway so
we're gonna do bed and talked a little
bit about so there are some issues with
Roberts counts and I sort of referred to
them right you are saying min documents
frequency max document frequency what
like what level are you gonna set those
at like you're gonna probably have to
tune that a little bit but really is
that like a sensible way of doing it
like generally in you know machine
learning or statistics generally you
hard-coding a bunch of like cut-offs
doesn't there's probably a better way
right there's always a better way than
that and so thinking about we're all
word count we already saw that like
without removing stop words you get a
bunch of noise and generally we wanna we
don't want to treat every word as the
same right because they're simply not so
think of the two in this example here
where this book is about biology this
book is about history right in those two
expressions couldnt anybody have an idea
of what is the most important like if
you had to pick one of those words in
either of those examples what would you
say is the most important to what that
that sentence is about
yeah book right and the subject is
probably pretty important but say you're
trying to like you know classify what
topic you know where that were to put
this book library idea 15 exactly that's
what that yeah so I would say that
history and biology should be weighted
as more important as is about this and
even book so is there a way a sound way
of operating important words and
discounting important unimportant words
and yes the answer is yes there is and
that's term frequency inverse document
frequency basically this is just thought
of as taking your word counts and
weighting them
according to how informative they are
about that particular document and it's
pretty easy document frequency is the
count of the number of documents in
which a particular term appears the
inverse document frequency sorry I just
put an N here but it's a number of
documents over the the number of
documents that that term appears in and
so you can imagine if that value is
higher then you want to give it a lower
weight because it appears very common
across you can imagine the word the
probably appears in every single
document that's gonna have a pretty
lower weight basically one way if it
appears in only one document then it's
basically gonna have the way to pen
which means it's it's exceptionally rare
it just pertains for to that document
particularly and so you can think of it
as just you know up waiting the most
informative words about that particular
document and then there's additional
processing that goes on top of it which
I won't really dive into but you know
the deal with situations where words
never appear and in particular corpus as
opera and I think it's a little bit
clearer an example I work better when I
look at it in the chart but as I said
before right like Julius Caesar and
Henry v are about wars and battles right
and so the word though the weighted term
frequency the term tf-idf value for
battle and Julius Caesar is pretty high
compared to fool and wit which are not
particularly that informative they don't
really have that much to do with Julius
Caesar and it's battled us you can still
you see the same stuff with like
individual characters like Romeo
Falstaff things like that
higher inverse document frequency any
questions on that that's a little bit of
a complex idea that or in Swift diving
attack
like I should be checking the chat and
people questions okay
yes I appreciate everybody helping
people with tech right now that's that I
really appreciate that thank you
so yeah um I might have missed this but
did you give like a formal definition
for both vocabulary means in this
context it sounds like it might have
something to do with word frequency but
I don't let me try yet miss that yes
sorry I'd like yeah I didn't I didn't
really formally explain what a
vocabulary isn't and I should have
vocabulary is basically all of your
tokens right it's your inventory of
tokens so when we were doing all that
like fussing around with tokenization
and things like that those are the
things that you might that the upshot of
that is basically to create this
discount vectorizer I know in a way that
it can so there's two different ways you
can do it you can fit it to your corpus
and give it some parameters in which
it'll create that vocabulary actually I
don't know why I'm pointing at it and
not just showing you exactly what comes
out of it the term vocabulary that I'm
using actually I'm just stealing from so
I can learn right so you can actually
access this vocabulary oh my gosh sorry
okay yeah you can access this vocabulary
and these are the the index and indices
for those different vocabulary words and
so by fitting it and I think who
referred to this by fitting it basically
you you gave it these parameters you
gave it this tokenizer and it's gonna
create this vocabulary for you before
this is fit it doesn't have a vocabulary
and you can a really cool trick that
I've messed around with before is to
give it its own vocabulary just
predefined vocabulary for it so let's
just call this a right and so now to
count vectorize if we ask for its
vocabulary it's gonna say I don't have a
book
yeah I think it'll be
this is none right so because you
haven't fitted or you haven't specified
a vocabulary for it it doesn't it it
doesn't have a vocabulary so once you
fit it now it has a vocabulary does that
make sense
the case where you want to give it your
own vocabulary meaning you want is an
inventory of tokens it will be in Creole
dictionary words its inventory of what
you expect to find out of your
tokenization function right
I can't possibly English dictionary or a
finance pictorial apology dictionary you
can yeah idealized form they do have to
organize those biology definitely or
right so it depends right so you're
expecting when you pass it a vocabulary
you're expecting that when scikit-learn
applies the tokenization that you've
specified or its default organization
that it's gonna find those exact like
words that you're giving it in that
vocabulary if it does not find those
exact words that you're doing in the
vocabulary it will basically just give
like it'll say like zero right like that
deduction that document has no loading
on any vocabulary then tokenization can
be harmful well I wouldn't say it's
necessarily harmful it's like it's a
choice that you make right by specifying
vocabulary so I've used count vectorizer
when I'm looking for particular tokens
right it's actually a really neat way of
searching for a particular token I've
used that this is / - in one example
I've used it with Chinese text right and
I've passed it the tokenizer from a
library that's called giba that does
this sort of tokenization for Chinese
characters and I was looking for
particular tokens or sets of tokens
sorry I'm jumping around a little bit
but something I don't really touch on is
that you can a token could be multiple
words long right and so you could say my
vocabulary is this word this word plus
this word you know it's Bob it's Bob
Dole it's Bob president Bob Dole or
something like that right like it's I
don't know why I picked that sorry for
that example but you know you can you
can use it in
a number of different wines very
flexible so sorry before food ask you
one last question on the same topic
president what when I arrived the word
president for token would I not get two
different tokens for other words
president Presley and then maybe
something wrong no no unless you're
unless you're tokenization it does
something like splits it up by
characters okay so yeah let's move ahead
so this is the count vectorizer and I
just turn into dataframe visualize and
then there's tf-idf factor I to this am
at there this is because so I could
learn does some additional magic that's
not just as simple as Andover DF and you
can see very quickly we just see that in
this set of documents we would say
probably good bad and great are the most
informative words in any different
sentence and you know we see that they
have the highest a term talking with
inverse document frequency weighted term
frequency out of all the words cool so
this is an example so let me see
okay so I'm not gonna go actually into
this exercise what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to go just lightly over topic
models because it's a pretty huge area
but I want to at least touch on it so
that folks can look at the slides at
home mess around with the examples and
feel free to ask me questions and things
like that I just don't know I don't know
if we're gonna have the time to go in
extensively to them so let me just touch
on them pretty briefly the idea is with
topic models as you know hey we have
these informative vectors but they are
document term matrices right they're a
distribution over the entire vocabulary
defined above
probably it makes sense to distill that
information a little bit doing that not
only kind of constraints or feature
space a little bit but likely each
individual token is not that important
but there's some information shared
between these different tokens and that
is sort of the idea of what topic models
is trying to do it's trying to basically
discover these these major themes that
pervade this unstructured collection of
documents so this is quote from from
play so the idea is that a document is a
function of a set of topics topics are a
function of a set of words and I'm going
to get very complicated very fast real
quick but a lot of these topic models
can be broken down into the idea of just
I mean this and actually getting this
get straight to this taking your data
and representing it as a distribution
across different archetypes so instead
of vocabulary now we're looking at
individual archetypes and those are can
be defined as as you know principal
components those can be defined as
topics those going to defined in a
number of different ways and I highly
highly recommend this talk by laymen
McInnis because basically he turns all
of these different models into matrix
factorization problems with different
loss functions applied to them and so
but the general idea
and he lays this out really clearly is
that these sets of techniques are
essentially trying to find these lower
dimensional representations of the
individual documents and those lower
dimensional representations in the
context of topic models are considered
are called topics or the you know a set
of the set of archetypes that have the
individual words of the vocabulary
weighted in some way across them
apologize for all the hand waviness I
just want to kind of like dive dive into
it go to the to the code a little bit so
so people have material to work with so
I don't really dive into LSI here but
LSI is essentially an adaptation of
principal components for for text
information for document term matrices
and non-negative matrix factorization is
essentially just this LSI but with a
constraint that all of the loadings
across the different archetypes have to
be positive the idea being that it makes
more sense to have a positive loading on
a particular topic rather than a
negative loading like what is a negative
loading on the topic to me it's kind of
hard to interpret and then the other
example that I'm just going to be going
through code for is latent airplay
allocation this is an extremely
complicated idea that is very well
explained in this article linked to here
but the idea is that each it kind of
goes back to this idea that I talked
about before the individual talk
documents are the result of a process of
a sort of generative process where an
individual you can imagine that like to
create the words in an individual
document you were selecting a set of
topics that are what it's about and then
those those topics have certain sets of
words that are representative of them
and those words then create the document
right so that each document it's a
generative model from words to topics to
documents
and I'm not gonna even touch on this
because this is super complex okay so
let's just go to the code so we can
touch on it at least lightly I have this
function just for displaying components
I found this very useful utility for
looking at the results of these topic
models and so we're gonna initialize the
tf-idf vectorizer and account vectorizer
we're gonna run those through
non-negative matrix factorization and
land directly allocation worth noting
latent dirkly allocation wants count
vectors that is because of the certain
assumptions of the generative model of
Lda so just I've no seen people make
that mistake before but it's worth so
I'm just specifying I'm pretty
specifying a number of components number
of topics here so running that takes
some amount of time because LBA is a
little bit slow you get these individual
components which are across your
vocabulary you have some measures of how
well the solver sort of did and finding
these archetypes and then you can just
display these components using that
function that I have before which so now
you have these ten different topics and
you have the words that are have the
highest loading on those individual
topics words that are most
representative of that particular topic
non-negative matrix factorization here
works a little bit well I'm just seeing
it work better generally but you can see
kind of a cool thing here where topic
number seven seems to be talking about
reviews that are for adaptations of
books and then topic number nine is
seems like it's talking about horror
effects or are movies particularly and I
don't know if people see other ones
warp speed apologize for that but I
wanted to make sure to leave ample time
for questions thoughts and discussion
hae-bin
thank you so much for the wonderful
presentation I have a question like when
you input a file suppose I have a paper
and it has introduction abstract
discussion different sections
I want to apply different rules to each
section can I do that different rules as
in different vocabularies yes yes
exactly yeah now stop words at different
sections so like is it possible yeah I
don't know if people have thoughts on
that okay thank you I would have to
break that and run separate analysis all
abstracts together okay all details
together all summaries together the
conclusion sections okay thanks yeah you
can also I mean you could fit your
vocabulary to every single word
depending yeah I mean it doesn't seem
like depending on like how you're
dealing with like small you know a small
corpus you could just probably take
every individual word that appears and
then you know do some exploratory
analysis there to see like what words
are most likely to appear in certain
sections or subset or document term
matrix in some way to mess around with
that I think it depends you know what
you're trying to do yep thank you thanks
Ben sure using this code base here that
looks like you've corrected your topic
modeling and you have many more features
in terms of scale you are using a little
luck every dime I don't know how big a
computer it was but how many documents
and you give us an idea about scale
number of documents how big though every
and nice to give a sense of scale idiot
performance yeah so it depends I mean
these things all of these things that
I've shown you so far are extremely like
light computationally right the thing
that you know you might run into is if
you have a huge corpus or you're using
every single possible token or every
single to possible character in in the
corpus then you might start things might
start exploding real real fast but these
strategies I haven't found that use for
having every single character I am even
particularly seeing it used for using
every single word I don't know I think
compared to some of the state-of-the-art
NLP stuff this is very lightweight what
we're working with theater so I don't
foresee much problem I see this is very
eminently scalable right like you could
have this on an isolated like a mobile
device or something like that a problem
you get and you run into problems when
you're dealing with large architectures
that you have to with tons of parameters
throw them in there I don't know if
people have thoughts on that as well
in terms of my thinking when I first
take this your code here and train it on
maybe 500 documents or 1,000 documents
100,000 document so that I can predict
maybe the good or bad that you showed or
what topic is this document belongs to
it also use this kind of a tool set for
predicting topics within a document and
I could train it what would be my
training set I mean what how large today
I created and if I have infinite data to
clean how much can this codebase handle
in a single nodes and are you can I pass
in 500 megabytes 100 megabytes I think
it depends it's very dependent on your
resources that you have again these are
lightweight things I have here but
things need to be tuned to your specific
needs right and you can make a lot of
choices to cut down on the complexity
hey Ben this is sandy thank you for a
wonderful presentation I have a question
regarding - you know one of the cases
I'm a trained so I'm trying to you know
going through the topic model for some
of the survey that I have and the most a
survey that have like you know tax
things because you know people will you
know freely add some questions regarding
to some of the text has questions so I
wonder like it's author does you know
topic modeling is there anything else I
can do you know because they don't like
for example based on the sample here it
looks yet like definitely we can extract
some useful information from nine topics
here but like is there anything else
that we can do to cross holiday or you
know to like further on like beyond this
like is there anything yeah yeah for
sure
there's there are so many different
directions you can go this is these are
useful features so if you have any sort
of labeled information you can use these
as informative features
in a classification model and run things
through it that way
you could do some amount of so like
there's there's measures for how I don't
know if this sort of answers your
questions but this measure for how well
this model is doing in terms of fitting
these topics to your to your data or
reconstructing the data from the topics
that it's generated and so you can see
by doing a bunch of different design
choice is a bunch of hyper parameter
tuning see if you can reduce this
reconstruction error and then you know
that you're having pretty informative
features it this is usually for
unlabeled data but you can use it to
enhance labeling you can see you know
based on this lower dimensional
representation you can do some sort of
clustering and then with your limited
labeled set you can say like okay all of
the positive labels fall into this
cluster across these topics and so I can
probably say okay anything else that's
in this cluster probably also is a
positive class or a positive class with
some probability support is like top
emolia can kind of have some like
menuing input into this model for
example these two looks similar I'm you
know we'll can cool them as one topic is
up to what's right and then would that
be another input for this model sorry I
haven't used this well I'm just know
anyway whether it is possible to do that
like yeah I mean there's you know
there's so much creativity oh you can do
with either these are informative
purpose like if I I'm gonna get a little
bit go a little bit overboard here but
if I was going to explain all of natural
language processing in one word it's
basically taking text and turning into
representations and that applies to the
most advanced transformer model and to a
word word count right so you can use a
lot of the pre-trained model sort of out
of the box even the most advanced ones
will basically give you a representation
that is just a numeric representation
that a machine can then make you so for
the classification model or you can we
didn't we didn't talk about here but you
can do similarity type measures between
those different vectors so the answer is
you're getting features out of this
approach and you can do you can add more
features you can concatenate them you
can do you know a number of different
things that's good thank you so much
yeah of course yeah other other thoughts
or I mean open to add a question about
going back to the the dictionary
attribute that was available after you
use the fit method so yeah so it sounds
like it seems like there's there's a
dictionary for each in your loop each
feature in your data frames so what if
you don't have so what if it's like a
situation where it's not supervised
learning where you don't have features
in that situation does it make sense to
define a vocabulary or how would you go
about I guess identifying if you had
multiple vocabularies or how do you even
define a vocabulary in that situation
well so this is all unsupervised right I
didn't actually make use of the negative
or positive labels that are that are
here yeah I was just using them to say
like do we get some discriminative
information I see I see so it so that
grouping it came up with on its own and
then you sorry yes so obviously confuse
that part a little bit more yeah um so
this piece particularly right yeah
that's right that's right yeah okay so I
mean I I split it I thought it was
interesting to look at what you can do
without even fitting a model to it um
yeah but right yeah I mean like I have
to separate corpuses right but you can
think of an example where you have two
separate corpuses like documents that
came before a certain day and documents
that came after a certain date so like
trying to think of an example like
before somebody declares their candidacy
for president I don't know why I'm
certain presidencies here and and after
in news articles right and seeing like
what words appear alongside this
particular person's mentioned verses
prior to this period right you don't
really have it you you don't really have
a supervised learning problem there you
just have a before and after and you can
just see from exploratory analysis oh
the word president appears a lot more
after they declared their candidacy than
before so so what if in this particular
situation you're negative and positive
reviews were in one corpus yeah I mean I
think that what would so I mean I think
there's a ton of different approaches I
think you know you have this distilled
said you can still run this whole thing
without you know I I ended up fitting
this entire topic model on all of the
reviews yes so I just basically took all
the reviews so these are all the topics
across all of the reviews so it would be
neat I don't think it would have come
out if one topic was negative right but
you could you know in in sort of
top-down investigating these maybe these
are things that only you find some
discriminative if you do like a
clustering right unsupervised approach a
clustering you find that all the
negative reviews tend to appear in this
set of clusters and all the positive
reviews which here in this set of
clusters so you can do some sort of like
labeling like that or some sort of
curation like that okay thank you so
much yeah of course yeah these are all
it's all like I wanted to make it like a
diagram but I didn't get a chance to
where it's just like how noisy is the
data and how much it is like a art
versus like a like science so like if
you have a very structured data set like
a lot of these models are trained on
like questioning answering data sets
they're super structured right and then
it's just a matter of optimizing on top
of optimization right but like when you
are just entering into a problem where
you have all this
like data and you have no idea what to
do with it then it's all really a matter
of like what am I trying to do what
works things like that it's a little bit
more nuanced so it's not like a brawling
approach there's just different
approaches
hey Ben sure well great presentation
thanks for that man you know I'm
interested in this McInnis matrix
factorization thing you talked about but
when I go to that link it goes to a
thing on dimensionality reduction and I
was wondering I can't seem to find the
matrix factorization video or talk yeah
it is I am I am let me just make sure
that the link is correct
it looks interesting both of them do
actually yeah yeah I mean it's a
super-fast it's needed 60 yeah he talks
about matrix factorization in as a
mentality reduction technique gotcha
okay thank you appreciate yeah yeah any
other thoughts discussion points
considerations ideas
you
you
cool well I mean we can continue but
sorry and somebody yeah that is there a
way like when you do cluster analysis
you can use silhouette with and things
like that to figure out how well your
clusters have been created is there are
there topic models that have a similar
let's see kind of metric for each one of
the topics they created like how well
they work for a particular topic you're
asking yeah yeah
he said they they happen for the whole
thing yeah proof I I imagine you could
redo the reconstruction error just hard
like just mathematically and just like
force it to only use two topics or one
topic or whatever yeah that's just my
thought and there might be a better way
of doing it I don't know if people have
experience there yeah I know no that's
good you I think he also said that you
might use these features to create
clusters and then once you're there then
you have the metrics that I'm asking
about anyway sounds good
yeah yeah yeah brain how will they hang
together yeah that's that's true like
how discriminative these different
topics are yeah it's good point cool all
right well unless there's other
questions or you know feel free to reach
out we'll just close it here and then
Tyler are there any things you want to
close out with
and then just wanted to definitely say
thank you I think this was awesome a lot
of great content so I just wanted to
definitely tell folks please go on -
Bence github and reuse some of this
information and reach out with any
questions so all of that will will be in
the content and the only other thing
that I think we want to give a shout out
for is the meetup that we have coming up
next month so just a reminder please go
on our meetup page definitely get
connected on our slack slack channels
stay up-to-date about what's going on in
folks if you're interested in presenting
something definitely reach out and as
well as if you're interested in getting
more involved with organization right
now that we're remote organizing is a
little bit I would say easier so I think
I definitely encourage you guys for you
thought about it before definitely try
to start to get involved now we'll be
here hopefully every month through this
virtual new virtual world we're
experiencing so definitely again big
shout outs have been phenomenal content
great stuff I have a lot to cover now
over the next few days thanks everyone
thanks for coming thanks for being thank
you thank you thank you